se dirige-t-on vers une baisse des
tensions dans la crise du crédit yens au
terme d'une réunion de plus de huit
heures sous médiation franco allemande à
paris kiev et moscou sont parvenus à
s'accorder sur le maintien d'un cessez
le feu dans l'est de l'ukraine pour la
france cette réunion envisagée comme un
test a permis de constater que les
russes étaient disposées à une
désescalade
une nouvelle réunion aura lieu dans deux
semaines à berlin en revanche la tension
ne retombe pas entre la russie et les
etats unis washington refuse la demande
de moscou de fermer la porte de l'otan à
l'ukraine et menace de sanctionner
directement vladimir poutine le point
sur la situation avec notre
correspondante à moscou vera goffman
après une longue pause les conseillers
politiques des chefs d'état du format
normandie se sont réunis à paris pour un
marathon de pourparlers qui a duré plus
de huit heures il faut être guidé
uniquement par les accords de misc et
alors il ne sera pas nécessaire d'armé
ou de se tenir financièrement l'ukraine
où le dôme basse c'est ce qu'a déclaré
l'envoyé spécial russe dmitri kozak lors
de son point presse c'est une nouvelle
discussion à paris sont intervenus à
l'issue d'une série de réunions entre
des hauts responsables russes et
américains et des membres de l'otan dans
un contexte international
particulièrement tendu plusieurs pays
occidentaux états unis en tête ont
récemment renforcé leur soutien
militaire à kiev prétextant une
prétendue volonté d' invasion de
l'ukraine par moscou la russie a démenti
à de nombreuses reprises scénario et
considère pour sa part comme une menace
les déploiements militaires effectuées
par le temps à ses frontières je vous
propose d'écouter
nous avons eu une conversation difficile
mais c'est peut-être la première
conversation sincère qui nous a permis
de faire l'inventaire de toutes les
questions liées à la mise en oeuvre de
l'accord de minsk et au règlement du
conflit nous avons convenu qu
indépendamment des divergences sur
l'accord de minsk entre l'ukraine et
certains districts des régions de
donetsk et de louhansk le cessez-le-feu
devait être respectée sans condition le
respect de ces accords sur le
cessez-le-feu incombe aux forces armées
ukrainiennes et au groupe armé des
districts spécifiques des régions de
donetsk et de louhansk en ukraine c'est
l'essence même de la question sur
laquelle nous nous sommes mis d'accord à
tout souscripteur à cottonwood selon me
tricaud zac elle a été convenu de mener
des consultations étatique
supplémentaire pour le prennent et
d'autres participants et à leurs reçus
sont rencontrés à berlin dans deux
semaines afin d'essayer je cite de
trouver des solutions à tous les
problèmes qui n'ont pas été résolues
depuis sept ans